i'll try this again all right so this is
on house bill 490 we're discussing i
passed out an email i asked the biggest
i think discussion point
that we want to have is around the
definition of firearm which was the
latest ad to the bill
i sent out
the definitions as research by house
community services we have firearms
defined in three different places in our
statutes
the current amendment reference does uh
reference by incorporation of the
federal statute and there's some
concerns about doing that
um so we'll just start with the
conversation on what what the idea is
again this i believe this amendment was
added um specifically to deal with uh
superior court cases that are now
tackling where felons who want to hunt
with muzzleloaders are basically in
charge with felons in possession of
firearms and that was never the intent
of the definition so i think the new
definition is an attempt to clarify that
and fix that
interpretation by the judicial branch
so i'm not sure if i got all that right
but if i didn't then let's talk about it
all right
so
again looking at the on the definition
of firearm
let me see if i can get um
dan can you go get us copies of the bill
please of 490. uh so everyone has a copy
i'm not sure everyone had a copy i
thought they'd be here this morning
um
let me pull up the current amended
version here
mr chair you have you do have a new
amendment though to add to this right i
have i have what the senate passed
so i believe is what the the bill that
dan will print out is the current
version of the of the bill right but you
have new language to i don't and that
was i wouldn't have a discussion because
i can recess the committee and draft
language i in looking so in my looking
at this and i'm looking at the history
of i think the
the history changed when we in
if you look at our say well the new the
current version by changing spell
projectile by action of of an explosive
it used to say gunpowder
and by by action of gunpowder and that
was meant to keep black powder out of
the out of the conversation um
however
somewhere along the line we changed this
definition to say
um
to say explosive and that's where we
have our issue is this courts of ruling
black powder or gunpowder identical
creates an explosive accent which fires
a projectile and so the word explosive
is our problem i think um
and how we correct that to say that we
can go back to the gunpowder definition
then explicitly
my thinking is we go back to the
gunpowder definition then and make an
explicit statement that black powder is
not included in the definition of
firearm
and that would be cleaner than
referencing the federal federal language
but i'm open to discussion on that
i like what you what you said
so the amendment if we were to do one
would say we'd go back if you look at um
the email i sent out that has a history
under number one just i'll use this
definition because it's cleaner
you'll see a note under number one and
it says firearm means any weapon
including a starter gun which
will or is designed or maybe readily be
converted to expel a projector by force
of gunpowder so i want to use that
definition go back to that definition
where we were
and then add
the the specific exemption of black
black powder this firearm shall not
include
uh a weapon starter gun um or weapon a
starter gun that is uh powered by black
powder
senator go ahead
so um
my i just want to make sure that our
the question is whether
i understand and support the exclusion
of black powder
fine
but i'm just what i'd like to know if
your research has revealed this that if
we
say gun powder with the exclusion of
black powder
are there any other explosives that
might
propel a projectile that is not included
under the definition of gunpowder
so your question is there any other
weapons that would be
that would fire a projectile by way of
black powder no basically no my question
is are there is
does the definition explosive include
any method of propulsion
that does not include gun powder or
black powder for instance rambo with a
thing
right so again but that's but that's the
arrow isn't projected by gunpowder right
but that's a you know so it'd be but
colonel might have an answer for us if
he's listening to the conversation he
okay
all right fine i just you know the the
miracles of modern chemistry right i
just you know i i i
wouldn't want to make sure i wanted to
make sure we wouldn't
we're putting a loophole in here that
some other
form of chemical reaction that can by
our projectile would not would now be
excluded but if the assurance is that
there is no such thing although maybe
somebody in their garage is somewhere
then then it's okay
i am sure some lawyers somewhere will
find a loophole somewhere that they'll
try to exploit so
in everything we do we may want to
exclude
excesses of alcohol which have been
known to cause
incidents
i think for most people the difference
between explosive and gunpowder is not
understood to be
black powder
so if we put in that we add it except
for black powder
that would be clear to everyone
right it'll be shall not include for
definition purposes it shall not include
projectiles fired by black powder
correct
so if i may
so your suggestion seems to be that
leave explosive
but then say
uh for the purposes of this chapter the
term explosive shall not include black
powder
i i think that accomplishes the same
thing i'm okay with that unless someone
could see some other loophole that we
just created by doing that
um so yeah so your definition we want to
leave the original the current rsa the
current definition which says
expel a projectile by action of an
explosive however this chapter shall
this uh chapter shall exclude
um uh weapons and starter pistols
um
i think they'd say for the purpose of
this chapter the term explosive shall
exclude black powder okay
i mean i'm sure
i'm sure somebody in ols will figure out
the much more elegant and correct
phrase it but i guess that's what we're
trying to get at
is that what you're suggesting
representative
more or less what you're suggesting
yes more or less i you know you could
just add by action of
an explosive other than black powder and
that would do it
and that's the simplest solution i would
think
i'll recess and then we'll we got to be
back here anyway it'll give me time to
run to ols give them the language
they'll draft it for us we'll come back
and get the exact language and then
if everyone's okay with that then i'll
just and have ols draft it and have it
set up for signature is everybody okay
with that language we'll say for the
purposes of this chapter this definition
shall not include
uh weapons fired by
that would include a muzzleloader and
that kind of thing
we are um
done
now we gotta wait till 9 30 for the next
one so go get a cup of coffee biobreak
the only discussion point is around
who should who should make the decision
um in the senate version of the bill
they have they amended our bill
we had it going to the commission
um for an appeal process and the
senate wants to go to the executive
director so i'm going to speak to the
house mission as an amendment in front
of you i cleaned up some of the language
and one of the reasons i cleaned it up
is because the hearing process
the senate left in section one of the
bill which changed the duties to include
an appeals process but then changed the
appeals process in section two to
say that the executive director was
going to do it so section one wasn't
needed but it's still in the bill um so
i cleaned up the timeline so it's nice
and clean
on the house position the idea is that
we don't think an appeal process going
to
um
a person's boss for lack of a better
phrase um the exact a single person
single bureaucrat um is the appropriate
action for a citizen who is in conflict
with the department because the the
executive director is going to take the
the position of this department and for
and support his subordinate and so the
idea was that this bill would go in
front of a commission more than one
person and on a majority vote of that
commission um the appeal could be turned
over i did incorporate the amendment
that's before you um a lot of the senate
language i agreed with
the language that said unless the
executive director issues a written
decision
that issuing a permit may pose a
significant disease
genetic
genetic ecological environmental health
safety a welfare risk of persons marine
animals or wildlife so that was the
senate language and i took that language
and i moved it in so it was good clean
language and i appreciated the senate
for adding it um
but again i i looked at this as similar
to
i go back to a lot of the hats i wear
one of the hats i wear is i'm a zoning
board chair and when they when the
zoning administrator rules on something
it doesn't go to the selectmen or town
manager for a decision it goes to the
zoning board of adjustment so there's a
multiple board of five people that
review the decision made by the um
decider to see if that decision was
accurate and then that board then votes
on either overturning that the decision
by the zoning administrator or not and
if it overturns it overturns it and and
it's moved forward if they support it
then the decisions support it so again
the idea being that a citizen should not
be
should have um a chance to present its
case to a board in in what i consider a
less biased board
in the commission so
um if any other house members want to
speak to the house position whether they
agree disagree
but again we think it should be more
than one person that makes the decision
the the agency has the absolute right to
deny a permit based on scientific
grounds present those scientific grounds
in writing to the uh applicant so he
knows why he's being denied and whether
or not he thinks he has a basis for an
appeal to the commissioners so that is
uh the basis of this email again
this thing is we had a citizen who has
told no
and then that was the end of it he had
no place to go and that's why this bill
came forward so with that logic in place
representative should we do that with
all the departments as well
where appropriate i'm completely fine
with that if there's a commission again
not all departments yeah i don't believe
the department of agriculture has a
commission or a board that could appeal
its decisions or anything else those
decisions go to um superior court i'm
not assuming i actually don't know
but
in the case where there's a commission a
board that you can appeal again we
talked about the idea that
every time we have a new law that comes
forward
uh in the fish and game department the
fish and game commission takes a
position so on the bills they they come
in and we hear from what used to be paul
sanchem and i forgot the other guy's
name i apologize the new guy uh woman um
but um it used to be that they would
come in and they would say the the
commission believes and the commission
thinks and i serve on jalcar and they do
the same exact thing when they bring in
rules they say the commission the
executive director created this rule and
the commission takes the position that
we approve we they agree with this rule
so again i think it's not uncommon for
them to take positions on on policy um
and they should they may review policy
so i think that a written decision by
the executive director denying a permit
could be reviewed easily by the
commission and if there's a sound basis
in fact and and
the
citizen gets the chance to give his
opposing position they can make the call
um having sat on fish and game for four
years and now r d for two years um
fish and game is unique in that it has a
commission
overseeing it and in my opinion
it is the checks and balances that
exists for a director position he's not
a commissioner of fishing game it's a
director and so the commissioners have
in the past commented on legislation
that has come to the fish and game
committee
so i think it's appropriate that in an
instance where
a
evaluation of a determination by a
director
of an appealed process has to have some
level where the
constituent in new hampshire can take
their appeal too
he can't be the only
decision maker especially when and i
agree with the representative of the
chair when when he may be
defending his agency or his employee so
there has to be a third party that can
make a
uh fair or balanced uh decision and i
think the commission is in place just
for that reason and has done that while
i'm not a fan of how this bill came to
us and it the piece of legislation uh
the issue it was tied around i think
when we come to the idea of creating an
opportunity for our constituents to be
able to appeal any issue at an agency to
a director position and i do would agree
with you that commissioners probably
have more control
in terms of
that they would not have checks and
balances
that's within their ruling you know
commissioners of dot or commissioners of
um you know other agencies so i think
within a director position that has a
commission overseeing it this would be
an appropriate measure in my opinion
thank you thank you mr chair um when
when i was hearing the bill apparently
there wasn't any type of uh you know
cogent type of appeal process as as is
correct that's correct right so this is
the senate the senate position is a step
forward is it not
it is
um
i really appreciate you
saying that um is it perfect
chances are not i was actually very
frustrated in the community because i i
really wasn't able to listen to a whole
host of testimonies so something people
came in with charts but were getting
rushed out and we were bottlenecked but
we did come up with a
at least
a start
and that that is the the senate's
position at this point
which
apparently there was that was one of the
uh the resting points when i left the
room that we got to fix this this this
appeals process and i think that's one
of the things that we were successful at
doing
uh and then we we just kind of gave it a
tweak
we're hoping that you would see it our
way and then come back another year and
then help us to uh to
go further with the process if if
necessary
so senator if i can ask can you tell me
what what is that
i'm gonna use the word hang up on using
the commissioners again it's not an
uncommon place for them to
take positions to make decisions based
on what the executive director brings to
them um and again i think that by having
it more than one person we do our
citizens the greatest good um by having
it's not just you got to convince one
person you got to convince a majority of
the board of the of the commission that
your position is right and the
commissioner's position is wrong that's
a pretty high hurdle for a person to
overcome
and it gives them
the uh the you know again they don't
feel like they're they're
swimming against the tide so to speak
well i'm looking at like a bird in the
hand syndrome right now so we have we
have something that that can uh be a a
fix but i know that uh i haven't spoken
with my colleague uh senator waters uh
and i don't put words in his mouth but
one of the things that i think he has
concerned with and i'll let him speak to
it but it's just that fish and game is
unique
and
we you know there tends to be a
politicization of issues and we don't
want that to creep into this
unique uh
department that and it is a unique
department it's self-funded blah blah
blah
so we were just looking at uh having a
bird in the hand and maybe coming back
and and saying hey you know if if this
isn't working we can definitely readjust
it i'd like that opportunity but i'd
like to see at least something move
forward and i really think that the
so senator waters yeah i don't need that
much i mean i think it's pretty clear
what the senate position is and it'd be
i think
you know we found a way to move forward
but if the house doesn't want to move
forward then the bill can die um but i
would say that in terms of your question
you know i was i spent my four years in
the house on fish and game
and those who may not have been here
remember back then that there were very
different circumstances at that point
uh related to around the commission
there was an audit and things have not
always been
the way maybe they should be
but the real point here is that
this ought to be a scientific based
decision
and that is what the chief of wildlife
bureau and what the director are
primarily beholden to
we are in very
you know difficult circumstances about
these vector disease vectors
um it's not just coveted in the deer
it's not just cwd
it's it's not just the avian flu we know
about those but one of the reasons that
it was not just colonel jordan and dan
bergeron who testified against the bill
and
thought that it ought to remain in the
hands of the director not the commission
because of the scientific issues but
notice we had eric anderson there i do a
lot of work with fisheries on the
atlantic states marine fisheries
commission
appointee from the legisl from the
legislature
and the
the
what an invasive species can do
in the marine environment or in the
aquatic environment on land are is just
devastating you know we we're seeing it
happening right now
uh in our coastal waters and so this is
this is something and once it's once it
gets out it's too late right so
um i think i think we made a good step
forward with this i i agree there ought
to be an appeals process i think that's
kind of universal to our function of of
open and transparent uh government um
but i think we do need to trust the
director here and the scientific staff
on it so i i think we've as the chairman
said we made good progress i think we
can pass this bill as the senate
um dealt with it and if it proves to be
does not work
um
then we'll be back at it but i think
this this this will work
thank you mr chairman and i i do notice
that that
colonel jordan is here
and i know that the the house had led
other people to speak on you know in
committee of conferences that i was
wondering if we could ask his opinion
sure right after set of the guidance of
course
i'm wondering if we have to have an
either or paradigm or could you say
something like the director in
consultation with
the commission
the director would retain the authority
but we bring the commission in as well i
i
i have to respect the fact that the
commissions change
commissioners change the knowledge level
their changes when you have an
established base of knowledge within an
agency and dealing with the disease
vectors that we're talking about the
invasive species covet you pick whatever
it is
i don't think it's unreasonable to have
the commission
working with
the director
i'm not sure we have to have an either
or
look we felt this was consistent to have
this go to the director as well the
problem we get into with the commission
is they meet one they're part-time they
meet once a month well we're worried
about that time frame issue if i can't
get them all together
and the other the other issue that i
have right now i have an awesome
commission
i don't always have that quite honestly
and so i'm concerned about future
commissioners i think the director is
where we do our license appeals to the
director the search and rescue
uh billing goes through the appeal
process goes through the director a
citizen can appeal there free of charge
they don't have to hire anybody
and then you know beyond the the
director if they're not happy with that
and they want to challenge that in court
then they do that with with all these
other things and i think following that
same time
that same um
setup would be appropriate here uh it's
going to help us meet those timelines
that have been placed in the bill the
the limit of days where we're not going
to have to worry about a commission
meeting so i think the director is very
capable of making that decision he makes
all the others so this would be just one
representative
thank you mr chairman my question to
senator who uh
proposed that the director will be
involved also with the commission
um my question is
the director is going to be a voting
member or not not you know i'm trying to
understand i think he's the final
decision
representative i believe he makes the
final or he or she makes the final
decision as to the uh
how the appeal will go
follow up mr seven what
so
if he's the final decision so that means
that
the commission doesn't have any function
but so whatever we are trying to
accomplish you know the
transparency some place to go and
citizen's
right
it's not working if he's the only final
decision so
right and i i do appreciate the comment
and i think one of the things that i i'm
just gleaning and uh from from colonel
jordan's testimony is the fact that
sometimes you have good commissions
sometimes you don't have good working
commissions also
uh there is a you know do we have a
quorum do we have an emergency is there
uh if you're gonna meet quarterly or how
i don't know how how you meet but if
timing has something to do with it as
well and so
i would love to to get something passed
i would love to get the an appeals
process started
and working and then come back and
address this again in the next term
and
yes thank you i have a question for
colonel
how often do you have appeals to
decisions by the director or yourself
so on license appeals
we have
probably
probably 20 a year on license appeals i
don't
search and rescue appeals we have very
few less than five in a year
and with importation issues i'm i'm
going to tell you that we have very few
disputes there's only
a couple of times that this becomes an
issue um and and i think it is important
to have a way for people to appeal a
decision
um but it but it's not something that's
going to happen a lot
uh one other thing that senator guida
said if i may uh he he made a reference
to the director making the decision
after consulting with the commission
i think that piece of it would allow him
some freedom if we get into an issue of
a quorum as opposed to the way it's
written now where it's required as a
majority vote
so if we if it's possible to have the
director make the decision with after
consulting with the commission i think
that would that might free up our
meeting my concern is that meeting
framework getting a commission together
um every time that we have one of these
and being able to stay within that time
frame
reason i'm bringing the point up is this
is that
there's a truism
delay is the deadliest form of denial
and
a lot of the people that are importing
things and so forth
are quite frankly in business
and delay could
you know could be denial if it's drawn
out
and
and one of the common complaints among
my constituents is how long how long it
takes
to
push something past
a
a bureaucratic environment
that frankly is probably overloaded
especially in times of covet
and so i wanted to know whether this was
an exceptional thing if it was then it
would not be a big time constraint on
the on the department to deal with
and very in as you say there are very
few appeals
and and that would be our concern with
involving the commission is that time
issue that's going to add time to it
where now we have a system in place
where the director hears these appeals
on all these other issues and it works
pretty well we feel it would work well
for this as well
so
um
the other thing is that i've been
brought up is is that
contacting the how are these appeals
made are they made in person before the
department are they written or what
so we send out a letter with our in all
these other cases that i'm describing to
you we send out a form letter explaining
uh the decision that's been made and the
process to ask for an appeal
and we allow people to call in and
schedule that appeal or email back and
let us know or write a letter back and
we set those appeals up uh to be heard
by the director following that we have a
time frame later but it is a it's an
in-person uh absolutely face-to-face
hearing right and they all know at that
time whether it's it's agreed to or not
or they don't know that instant i don't
let the director i've i stopped the
director for making making the decision
with the person sitting in a room
because i think in some cases that could
place him in harm's way
so on some of these things so what i say
to folks on tape or record them all what
i say to them is the director will be
making a decision within a week to 10
days and you'll receive it that decision
in writing and then we get the decision
right outside license suspensions i get
i get those memos out within two to
three days of the hearing so that
because i know people are waiting well i
noticed in the senate version that you
have 60 days to to appeal right
right right and it seems like there's
like
a long
a long period between
striking the match and seeing if it
catches fire yeah and we i i gotta tell
you we don't none of i don't i can't
remember the last time an importation
permit went 60 days we make these we
know we make those decisions fairly
quickly and would allow for the hearing
to happen quickly i just i don't want
things i don't want the mechanical part
of this
as far as who has to hear it stretch out
that time or strength that's my concern
thank you very much that just does work
in favor of the
it does the individual making the
complaint it does so uh representative
egan
thank you mr chair um i think in
consensus we all want to make sure that
there's an appeals process i do highly
respect the point of view of senator
waters about that
scientists and experts are making the
decisions where i could be more
comfortable that the director makes the
decision in consultation with the
commission so at least there is an
opportunity for
the decision-making process to be moved
along and another set of eyes on it and
i'd be comfortable if that's uh an
amendment that sort of i think represent
uh senator excuse me senator you are a
senator i can't call you a
representative uh senator geider sort of
uh reflected that would be a good
sort of middle ground that i think we'd
all be comfortable with i would support
something like that i can tell you the
wording that could do it if you want it
if you look um
and the there
any person is denied a permanent
understand paragraph a may appeal the
decision in writing to executive
director within 60 days of the denial
executive director shall respond
after consultation with the
commission to the appeal within 60 days
why not it's consultation
give me one second senator i'm going to
try and catch up on that
that's line 14 so your line you're
you're on section b any person who's
done on a pyramid under
sub paragraph a may appeal the decision
writing to the executive director within
60 days of the now the executive
director shall respond to the appeal
within 60 days can you tell me where
that language was the executive director
shall respond
okay so i just have a couple comments on
this as long as we're we'll stick with
the senate version for right now and
look where i have some issues
um
one of the concerns i have is as they're
i'm a little concerned and maybe colonel
jordan speak to this we specifically say
in in statute by the senate version that
it's the chief of the wildlife division
shall respond i had changed it to the
executive director or as designee in the
language i used because i think you've
said colonel jordan before you didn't
have this process you didn't have this
responsibility somebody else in the
agency had this responsibility i don't
know if they're going to go back to that
we heard in testimony quite clearly
from
from fish and game that anything like
this should start with the
division of wildlife because that is the
scientist who's on top of this stuff so
that's that's why if it's an appeal
process it has you have a decision made
by
the um
wildlife
and then the appeal goes to the director
so that's why the senate did it the way
it did so if i'm not mistaken colonel
jordan that's different than the current
process which is you as the chief of law
enforcement are making this decision and
issuing the permit or not issuing the
permit now we're going to be telling the
agencies the chief of wildlife which is
a different person in in the agency and
and uh we we talked about that at before
the hearing in that i didn't feel i was
the appropriate person to make that
because the bi i'd we would feel more
comfortable the biologists make that
decision because it's a biological
concern and keep the director out of it
at that point and then have the appeal
go to the director for the final
decision after consultation if we if you
go that route with the commission
so let me just finish finish my i'm
finishing this sentence
so we have
the chief of wildlife division who's
going to respond to the request but in
the second sentence of that section it
says the permit shall be granted within
60 days unless the executive director
right so now we've moved that somehow
division is going to respond to the
request but the executive director is
actually making the decision
and so the question is should that
executive director language go back go
to the chief of the wildlife division
otherwise you have the executive
director appeal his own decision because
it's you've given him the decision in
that second sentence
well i think the problem there is the
timing again that you know once the
genie's out of the box here
of that
if he's said yes and the executive
director thinks wait a minute this is
terrible
decision executive thor the executive
director is the boss there not the chief
of wildlife so
um
you know there needs to be this
gatekeeper
they're really in the executive director
and uh then the appeal that he made an
appeal
with this proposed amendment would bring
in the commission so there are some
other eyes on it but this is not
i mean
i i'm just trying to emphasize because
of the work that we've done the last
couple years on the issues about these
potential diseases that this is this is
this is a system that requires caution
senator i'm not disagreeing with you
again i want to protect our our herds
and our and our flocks and whatever else
you call everything else that's around
the state um in our wildlife i'm just
looking at process right i'm just
cleaning up process so what in this we
have the executive director making the
determination and then we have the
executive director doing his appeal of
his own determination which doesn't seem
appropriate to me right again if if if
we're going to use the chief of the
wildlife division to make shall respond
to requests
then i'm guessing that it the second in
that second line
it should say if the
wildlife division determines that
issuing the permit the the
i'm just
you can't have the executive director
appeal his own decision he's already
made his decision that would be kind of
redundant
so either if we're going to leave that
language in there then it has to go to
the commission because that's the next
step up
so i'm trying to unders again this is a
process question senator guida i would
concur with that i would think that if
the wildlife folks are the biologists
that are going to do the scientific
analysis they issue the opinion or the
denial
um
and then that then gets appealed to the
director with consultation of the
commission that to me makes a sensible
process i would agree that you cannot
appeal to the very same person that
denied the request initially finally
senator geider the problem there though
is that
let's say that the director
the wildlife
makes a decision that
the executive director thinks is a
mistake
then it's too late
because if if under this it would be
that
if
if you see if the decision goes in favor
of the person
then there's no appeal right it's just
done
uh under this proposed change and that i
i'm nervous about that because i think
that
um the appeals process you know denial
then you have the the process but
in this case it's kind of like an
emergency
where the director says wait a minute
there's a significant problem here that
may not have been sufficiently
considered
if i might senator i think that
the director himself probably relies on
the knowledge of his wildlife people i
don't know i think the director's
position is more of a generalist he may
have certain specialties and experience
but i think he would rely on his
wildlife person
to make the scientific analysis and he
would then upon appeal review that
um i i i would say that
at some point we're going to have to
trust the department's science resources
to not make a bad decision and start
so
what i'm gathering you through this
whole discussion we have potential time
delays if we add an extra layer of
conversation
to this
we do not have an appeals process that's
working right now the senate
is offering
a start
and just by the conversation that we're
having right now it seems as though it's
getting complicated
to where we we should re
get a bird in the hand
come back
and
modify in the next session but i think
this right here gives us a process
to to get started
and then we can come back and we can
revisit this and you know with a full
hearing but i think um
as the representative said you know
uh time delayed is is
you know it's not
it's not working in favor of the people
that are wanting the appeals because yes
now we have an appeals process it's
going to go to the commission it's going
to go to this person it's going to come
back but we need a time
you know so
so my humble opinion is we have
something
let's go with this so senator again i i
a time delay the timing in your language
and the timing in my language going to
the commission are exactly identical 60
days and 60 days so it doesn't create a
delay for anybody right so between the
two bills there's no difference in time
um the the process is exactly identical
to 60 days for a decision 60 days for an
appeal 60 days for an appeal not 60 days
for a decision nope they both have 60
days for a decision in it built into the
so i just want to take that discussion
off so yeah we're leaving uh so we're
missing my only my only concern is you
have the executive director based on
your bill
appealing his own decision
and and i'm not sure how that suits
anybody so again i i think that
if we just make that one change the
chief of wildlife division right unless
the chief of wildlife division
determines it and i would add the word
in writing uh that issuing a permit may
pose a significant risk right and then
you appeal that decision to the to the
uh if they're denied by the chief of
wildlife i'm not i i'll accede to the
senate position with some minor changes
only because i think procedurally wrong
i think procedurally having us appeal
the executive director's decision to the
executive director is like asking me if
i'm going to change my own opinion
right
you know i've already stated my opinion
right and so um i think that
just making that simple change of saying
unless the chief of the wildlife
division determines in writing that
issuing a permit may pose that's all i'm
asking for is i think that change
fixes the problem so that we don't have
a a
stacked case against a citizen
repeat that one more time please so in
the second sentence the permit shall be
granted within 60 days of the request
unless the chief of the wildlife
division determines in writing that
issuing a permit
i'm sorry i just don't think we can have
something that says that if it takes you
60 days you get your permit i'm sorry
that's already the senate position
only thing i'm changing is to make sure
we don't have a the citizen doesn't feel
the guy who made decisions got to hear
because that's how your your bills cur
that's how the senate position is
currently written and i'm just asking
that the chief of the wildlife who you
put right in the front shall respond
right you already have that said that
that's the person responsible for making
the determination
i'm just guessing that we stay
consistent with that and says unless
that same person determines that issuing
a permit is bad
i really like to pass something and have
an appeal do we have just one minute yes
we're back in session thank you mr chair
i think right now i think we're going to
just uh have to uh
not a seed to the house and just leave
it as it is we're just going to keep
this senate position at this point i
really think we should come back another
session
fix whatever we would do but we got a
bird in the hand
that's where we're going to leave it at
this point and i i love you so you want
so we want to leave it so that the
executive director is going to appeal
his own decision we got to start we'll
move we'll move forward next
time trust me and i and i'll give you
but we are including that in
consultation with the commission in that
no no i'm just just the senate position
and i i understand that that that's
that's heartburn but uh
i i can give you my word that i will uh
read
we'll come back and and uh
re uh
address this
my my concerns with the commission it
adds extra time uh
so i i just
it's getting squirrely to me and i'm not
comfortable with that and making it uh
making a lot of these decisions on the
fly i'd love to revisit this
and
like i give you my word that i will give
you my best
when we come back next session to make
some changes if necessary
house members conversation do you want
to accede to the senate position i think
we're creating a logical fallacy in our
discussion where we have the executive
director appealing his own decision i
think that's just
we either trust the science we don't we
trust our biologists we don't and now
we're saying well we trust our
biologists but not really because we
want the executive director to
to actually decide and over possibly
overturn the scientists i i don't know
how that makes any sense but
are you do you want the bird in the hand
to take this kind of position or do you
want to want to walk too much talking i
want to hear my other two colleagues
first
representative
my thinking is uh
the commission is already doing this
kind of things you know in all different
ways
and the other thing is they represent
the you know all different part of our
state
so it will be more transparent it will
be voice of the people than how it feels
but then again i really don't want to
see that this thing dies here because
the number of people came here and all
the testimony and all the work and
everything the our work the clerical
work and all these things just dies just
because of that i really like to see
that we take another five or ten minutes
to think about how we can make a
compromise that is my you know
you know proposal to all of you
mac
oh
i am where
i'm reminded that we in the legislature
as juries are
in civil and criminal cases
the final word not the executive not the
governor not the judge and so there must
be a role for the commissioners in this
i would think
and so i am
in favor of the compromise
on the other hand the good senator said
a bird in the hand
is a great place to start and it's hard
i'm
we're a long way
we're closer to it
uh
perhaps the reason for an appeal would
be that the original application
would be modified by
recurring events and so forth
so i'm willing to go with the burden
hand at this moment
and with the experience that comes in
the next year with the advice of colonel
jordan
perhaps we can refine this further
so we didn't get to our body of law
overnight and i don't think we can
i
the feeling in the senate is such it's
either this or nothing
so i'm just going to ask colonel jordan
once because i i saw him bobbing his
head yes that i was right so that's why
i'm going to make him come up and say
i'm right um so again colonel jordan
you know again i'm i'm only i'll see to
the senate position with the one minor
change of the fact that i don't think
the commissioner i don't the executive
director should be appealing his own
decision that just doesn't the citizens
not gonna gonna feel that's right
they're like wait the same guy that
already told me no i've got to ask him
to change his mind and that just the
citizen is kind of left out in the cold
in my opinion um in the in this in this
process by doing this is it's might as
well not have a process because these
odds of this of the of the commission
are changing his mind is pretty or the
executive director probably pretty about
zero and so
um again
so
this is all about the citizen and
creating a process that makes the
citizen feel that they were heard they
were that they had avenues to do
something and so colonel jordan so how
do you feel about the idea of changing
the um that second sentence in this bill
that says unless the executive director
determines to unless the chief of
wildlife division determines which in
the first sentence is who we say is the
so i i'm not sure i'm looking at the
same version but but the way that we
would like to see it work we think
basing it on how we're doing it now with
these other decisions where the chief
the appropriate chief makes a decision
then if we give them that in writing and
and allow them an opportunity for a
hearing before the director to appeal
that decision
we don't involve the commission we don't
involve any of that delay
and then it's up to the chief to come to
the like i do for license suspension to
go to the director and say i made this
decision director based on this this and
this i defend my position
the person citizen gets to put in their
ideas and defend their positions very
much like a trial and then the director
has that final say to me
that's the appropriate way to do this
the same way we're doing all our other
processes
it works very well we haven't had any
issues with it and i feel if we could
get there with this we would have it i
do think an appeal is important i'm not
concerned about the director not being
involved in that first step because i i
think that's more appropriate for the
scientist in this case and then they go
and defend that decision with the boss
when people appeal that to the director
and leave the commission out of it
senator
the chief of the wildlife division shall
to request
for a permit within 60 days of a
submission
for a final request
sorry
so then then excuse me then strike the
next sentence
to strike it the permit shall be granted
and then um any person
who's denied a permit on this paragraph
may may appeal the decision in writing
the the
again the language we're looking at in a
senate position which is what was passed
um the only issue
that we're calling is the is that unless
the executive director that language
right there those four words and making
that being unless the chief of wildlife
division
that otherwise that's not the senate
position you've already passed this in a
position of that the permits granted
within 60 days if the agency doesn't
respond otherwise there's no recourse
what this would do
would be to say the chief of the wild
delights division shall issue a written
response request for permit within 60
then there's nothing after that until
you get down to b
any person who's denied a permit under
sub-aircraft a may appeal the decision
to write an executive director within 60
days of denial
your acceptance is a response
i would assume as colonel jordan has
indicated that the chief of wildlife
division is going to take into account
significant disease genetic ecological
environment health safety or welfare
risk to persons marine species or
wildlife
so the
chief of the wildlife division
makes a decision if it's a non-isle
the citizen can appeal to the executive
director
that's the process and what happens if
they don't make a decision what what
happens if they don't make a decision
that's the purpose of the second
sentence is the force action
make sure this is it doesn't just done
by delay we do this in a lot of bills
we're doing a lot more research i'm
the direct executive director shall
respond to the appeal within 60 days
now if at that point that it's still
denied and the person doesn't like it
they can go to court
so the question again comes back to if
the wildlife if the chief of the
wildlife division just chooses not to
act and just sits on it it says right
here in the sentence if you'll notice
the shell
issue written
written response to request for permit
within 60 days of the of a submission of
a final request
you got 60 days and you got 60 days
again senator so the question is if i
don't if the chief of wildlife does not
issue a ruling
just doesn't do anything with the permit
the permit submitted even though it says
shall they broken the law that may be
but the citizens still left hanging out
there
and and the point of the 60 day is to
force them to issue a ruling and if they
don't then the assumption's yes
mr chairman i think we've made an
awfully good
house members how do you want to go
they're not willing to move off their
language in any meaningful way that's
reasonable
that's not a compromise that makes the
bill worse fine
okay that's not a compromise the only
question we had was who hears the appeal
and who who is makes the decision those
are the two questions you're asking in
your version of the bill you want the
decision maker and now we're going back
on the fact that it's a shall that they
have to respond within 60 days
otherwise nothing happens to them and
that that's not the point the point of
the bill was to help the citizens and by
not putting a timeline in there that
makes it so that if they don't act
there's there's consequences then we've
done nothing for the citizen they can't
you will walk away guys could shall be
replaced with must
well it's the same language so it's
shallow must as a saying well shall is
optional must is a requirement nope
shall is may is optional
are you guys willing to walk away from
this i don't want to walk away from this
again i i think i'm just asking for
a clean up of the process now we want to
okay we're done
why don't i open the committee of
conference then on house bill 1586
fn and act relative to the likeness of
wentworth cheswell at the state house
um
the house position uh we do have a
side-by-side would you
are you
comfortable with
the side-by-side
do the senators have that jennifer yeah
okay
um why don't we start from
the point of view of um
hearing why the senate decided that uh
the unanimous decision of the house was
thank you mr chairman we're glad to
we had considerable discussion about the
fact that there is no known image of
wentworth cheswell
and um
that would put us in the position that
the language of the bill itself
could not work because it directed the
historical committee to accept the
likeness of cheswell whereas if there
was no possibility of creating a
likeness of him the historical committee
could never accept such a portrait
we did a lot of consultation
with the black heritage trail in new
hampshire i have to be a member of that
board and other groups have done uh
research on these areas and there was a
real kind of sense that if you
presented an image which in a sense was
fought
what can i say constructed or imagined
or invented
then we in a sense would be presenting
something that could be very
troubling in what it claimed to
represent
um what we know about cheswell is he had
his mixed mixed heritage um
and we don't know was he white skin did
he have straight hair or curly hair what
were his features we know none of this
and
for that reason it was feared that
whatever portrait was
was created would be
an invention and we've been
you know in many circumstances over many
years where people's imagined ideas of
african americans have been very
problematic
that you would be creating something
that was based on somebody's imagined
image of what a black person may or may
not have have looked like
so that's why we thought that what would
be really much more appropriate would be
to have a plaque
it could be prominently displayed in the
hallway where the revolutionary war
folks are commemorated right across the
visitor's center so we have high
visibility and the plaque as you go
around the state house it affords an
opportunity for much more information
about uh an individual
so that was our position and i i will
just say that that's basically what the
senate position is and i i don't think
we're i i would hope the house could
exceed to it because otherwise i fear
thank you senator um
anyone
from the house i'd like to respond
yes mr senator
thank you very much
thank you sorry
quote all right thank you so much
um
it's true we don't have an actual
picture of wentworth tiswell however
we have had in the past a portrait of a
governor governor kai's pronounced kai's
but spelled keys
for dozens and dozens of decades hanging
on the second floor only to find out
that wasn't him at all and people looked
at him and read the plaque and believed
the plaque and believed that image was
him
we also have an image of marilla ricker
from dover
and i mentioned to the artist that
for the photographs we have of her the
image looked quite different and she
said well marilla ricker looked very
severe she thought she'd take artistic
license with the portrait and soften it
so it doesn't look that much like
marilla ricker
we also have portraits of people wearing
tricorn hats and wearing wigs
we don't know exactly
what they look like
there is a problem here because we don't
know exactly what
wentworth has well looked like but
we could very well do a likeness and
then we all have the writings the
plaques underneath the portraits that
get plenty of details about these people
and we could introduce that portrait by
saying this is a likeness because we do
not have an actual image from which to
work
i think with the clothing that we would
put on him
and
uh whatever background we might or might
not use could be enough to give a sense
of when this man lived we know that he
was not 100
black we know that he was a mixed race
but he was the first person of mixed
race to ever be elected to any office in
this country and my concern is if we put
up simply a plaque
that all the people who all the visitors
from around the state and around the
country around the world who come as
well as the fourth graders who come
every year won't even look at a plaque
people need something to see an image of
some sort
and i was thinking recently when i was
down in portsmouth looking at the
amazingly wonderful tribute for the the
black heritage grave area
i don't know who stood for that image of
the woman standing there with her hands
but i thought we didn't know what each
one of these people really looked like
either
and granted we want to know what people
really look like but i think there's
enough information that we could
put up a likeness of him
document that it is a likeness because
we don't have an actual image going way
back to the 1700s and i think it would
be important because again people would
at least have some concept look at what
i saw at the state house
thank you
thank you if i may respond to that
senator
i was involved with the
african bearing ground
process there
and um the figures there if you read the
read about it was meant to represent
mother africa no person one was mother
africa and another was meant to
represented a person in bondage there
was no pretense that these represented
any living people they were symbolic
now
the issue here is you can look up the
decision of definition of likeness it's
a semblance resemblance or a portrait um
and i i just
and again i was also involved in harriet
wilson project which created the
monument for her first uh
woman of accurate descent to publish a
novel in the history of the world 1859
over in milford
and there was a very
very thorough process of discussing what
should be presented there because for
her in her autobiographical novel there
were extensive descriptions of her there
and also there was a drawing of her
there was a label of the the hair
restorer that she
she used um
do we really want to get in a situation
where we are saying to an artist well
and i will this is kind of conversations
that went along with the harry wilson
one well does does the person look
african enough or african-american
enough or what if the person
uh would you know was so like completely
that people look at the portrait and say
why you have a portrait of a
light complected or what visually would
tell you one thing about race
or if it is another kind of an image
that is not him but but features what
people might imagine our
african-american features whether it's
hair physiognomy or skin tone
then we have also i think
used 20 22 conceptualizations of what
racial depiction is
and i think that is something that has
been extremely problematic in our past
about creating these invented images and
i don't i also as an educator
i don't think that we want to
have our school children come in here
and present with what would be a false
image
a false image why would we be doing that
as a state legislature
to present a false image and i don't
know what happened with that portrait of
the governor that wasn't the port of the
governor i think it came down
and ricker at least you know artistic
licensed somewhat but it was off a
photograph look at the photograph and
sure you know it's she's a little
improved but there was a photograph
where alexander twilight who um you know
from vermont a
state representative up there founded
academy which is the building is still
there extraordinary individual novels
written about him
but there's a portrait and uh that i
mean there was a photograph
and that photograph was what what the
artist could use for the one that's
that was created so um
and i think also to presume we are an
age of images but to presume that people
cannot receive information other than by
having a you know a likeness or an image
or a picture i i think
really sells short our guides our
students are our public who
who could appreciate information and and
maybe let their own mind
kind of imagine what
um
what cheswell's life was like i will say
too
that we know what we know from wentworth
cheswell is that he really valued his
handwriting
that at that time as a person of african
descent to be able to sign your
signature meant that you were recognized
in the eyes of the law
this is an extremely important test
and he in his work in new market he
copied the town record because thought
the british might burn them in their own
deposit in the university of new
hampshire library and he signed a lot of
documents you can go online or you can
go see the originals and you'll see
his signature
and so if you want something from his
hand on a plaque
you know or that is a likeness or
resemblance you you know
and i i i could reference to you you
know the individuals who wrote you know
philosophy writing to george washington
you know uh or others writing to thomas
jefferson and um having that their
signature that their hand would be
recognized or the petitioners the slave
petitioners in portsmouth who wrote
their signatures very large you can go
up the state of arkansas because it
meant that their
their signature meant that they were
recognized as human beings so we have an
opportunity there to do something
but as i said the senate position is is
what is going to be here senator carson
confirm this
that we hope the house will exceed or
else the bill will die
i'd like to give the opportunity for the
prime sponsor to chime in
representative b lorenzo
welcome
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
my name is representative charlotte
dilorenzo and i'm this prime sponsor of
hb 1586 fn a um
you know i think it's really really
important that we get this portrait done
and displayed in the state house
mainly because of wentworth cheswell's
accomplishments his duty to the country
as a revolutionary war
soldier
um and all of the things that
he established in
my town of new market including a free
library
now
there's been debate about what did mr
cheswell really looked like
senator waters just mentioned another
character
historic character um
alexander twilight from vermont whose
portrait was unveiled on may 4th in the
vermont state house
i see a lot of parallels
with um
wentworth cheswell and
alexander twilight and
that just makes me more compelled to
support
this bill
as we know it passed in the house on a
voice vote
um
unanimously
and i think that we need to close the
circle on this and get this portrait
done
however we do it
and as for objections that we're not
quite sure what he looked like we don't
want his hair to be too curly we don't
want his skin to be too light or too
dark i think that we do have artists who
could project a really good likeness of
mr cheswell um based on his
ethnic
heredity
and based on
his descendants and what they looked
like
complete and and pass this bill thank
you
and
i'm open for questions
thank you
my understanding is
that um
the donor
group
where the portrait
was going to access
a painter who has
experience in
this type of issue of um interviewing
the descendants um
and and building that composite from
either not eyewitnesses but from from
documented um
history of
what they
what the relatives look like
um is that your understanding as well
that um
that is this person has experience with
that this this portrait painter
representative ruler
thank you
i just want to say that
one of the most important things that i
have seen here at the state house
is when the fourth graders come to the
state house
and
the questions that they ask when they
sit in rep's hall about the buttons and
about the pictures
and the times that i've been here
the little girls
that were fourth graders were thrilled
to see
women
women females on the wall
we have more diversity coming into the
state house now
with all
different
nationalities
including black
mixed race
the entire
gamut and wouldn't it be wonderful
for these children to identify
with someone
that is a mixed race
rather than
looking at a plaque and not
understanding that this person
is perhaps
like them
so i think
that is a most compelling reason
that we need to do it
they're not going to be looking the kids
are going to walk right past a plaque
and they're going to be looking at the
portraits
and i understand that it may not be
exactly but the most important aspect of
the picture
is that he was biracial
and partly black
thank you yeah if i may respond to a
uh you can do the science on it you do
the math or you can go to the scientists
on whether descendants provide any guide
when you get six to eight generations
down
um by the math you're at less than two
percent of the dna from that descendant
the way the dna is actually passed down
and i will use the scientific and
technical term that is you can find
internet by eight generations the amount
of dna from the original person is quote
unquote vanishingly small
so it is no reliable guide whatsoever
as to physiognomy or anything else about
someone who is eight generations
previous that's just the science on it
i will say secondly that i'm just really
anxious about going into the territory
of our imagining what well not
necessarily bi-raciated black
grandfather
person looked like at that time
and i you know i i'll just be personal
my our son is african-american
and uh he is someone who at a very early
age recognized the kind of images and
the presentations and the difficulties
in his classroom of kind of fantasized
images in fact they had you know
plantation images of happy slaves on the
schoolhouse wall of his fourth grade
and this is disturbing to him
and to see that someone would have
imagined
and again i i'd say representative i
mean are you going to sit there and with
a color chart disguise you know how much
look at the portrait wentworth of uh
alexander twilight look at that portrait
you think you're you know looking at a
quote-unquote white
you know with the photograph
and
um
so what what is it that would put up
there and try to tell the school
children that we are wanting them to
accept as a basically a racial fantasy
about who this what this person looked
like why would we even want to go down
that road
when we have a very good option here
thank you mr chairman
thank you
representative
i'm sorry senator richard did you have
something you wanted to come yes thank
you uh mr chairman i think
the place that we can all agree is that
wentworth cheswell
should be recognized and
was a very amazing person
but we feel in the senate that you're
doing a disservice to him to put up
a fictitious
portrait
now to
speak to the point of the fourth graders
i've been here with many of my fourth
grade classes just this week on monday
with jeffrey
the tour is done very well
things are pointed out it doesn't have
to just be a portrait but for people to
really recognize what this man
was about
will be identified
perhaps the best way to go is to do the
plaque rather than have a fictitious
portrait
have this man properly recognized and
honored and then maybe somewhere down
the road there are some historians there
can dig up something further of a
photograph maybe there's something
somewhere down the road but that's the
the senate position so thank you
thank you senator
um a quick question i have on the um
the senate version is
to accept a a gift um
is there a senate
provider
um
that is kind of boreplayed as to what we
do rather than spending state expending
state funds but i i can assure you that
there will be
the money could be raised perhaps by the
black heritage trail or other groups
i will assure you that we are you may
have noticed that a
marker went up in windham
last weekend for
uh to commemorate peop you know enslaved
in free black community in windham
there's one going up over in rock rest
in kittery
on june 4th there's going to be others
in dover and elsewhere i mean we have
this you know statewide trail and those
plaques cost
maybe three thousand each
um i
don't remember the most recent plaque we
put up the price but anyways yes so i'm
trying to give i should just give a
short answer to your question yes
there is
thank you
thank you mr chair you know i
you know i understand where you're
coming from i definitely get it because
um
you know i definitely don't want to
misrepresent somebody but
at the same time i think you know one of
you know i as a person of color i walk
around these halls and i you know i see
nobody that looks like me
um and i and i don't know if there ever
will be a portrait of somebody who looks
like me i hope so in the future um i
mean i'm part of the joy i get in the
fourth grade class coming over is when i
get to speak to my fourth grade
elementary school led street elementary
school and i get to speak to them in
spanish and the kids go bananas because
about half the school uh is our our
spanish speakers um which is incredible
um but one of
you know one of the things we're trying
to do here is trying to memorialize you
know
an amazing man um and and try to raise
up his legacy here in the state house
and i you know i worry about the the
optics of of of a plaque versus a
portrait simply just not being enough um
and that is and like and being enough is
just a longer conversation that we can
that that that happens and one of the
things i i get concerned about it's like
oh it doesn't rain it's to me it feels
like oh it doesn't it's not raised to
the level of stature of a portrait and
um
and i and yeah that just did
so this is it's a tip it's a difficult
decision to grapple with um and you know
that's why i believe you know we
we in the house want uh would love if
the the portrait rather than the plaque
so i may just add mr chairman if you
walk around the state house you notice
that some of the people of the of the
highest honors that we accord are medal
of honor winners and others
it's a it's a bronze plaque
um and i agree completely about needing
to diversify the representation of this
state through portraiture
um we have the opportunity certainly for
the you know the the first
housemate african-american house member
to be commemorated and portrait were we
to choose to do so
i hope people saw in the last week that
tom hooker died
what an extraordinary man an
extraordinary history of state and
national
service and his wife too i mean the
portrait of both an eleanor hooker
eleanor williams hooker what they did
together here in this state as pioneers
um extraordinary opportunity
i think with with them so there's no
shortage of people to commemorate in
such a in such a way and as i said
i i think we'd be
magnificently pleased with the results
of having this plaque and where it would
be displayed
and the stories that could be told about
it
um but we wouldn't be propagating um
a false image and so
i mean i i don't want to belabor it but
you know from senator carson who made it
very clear in conversation yesterday
where the senate was at and
i hope that the house will exceed
otherwise it's going to
have to just wait for another year
representable
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you senator waters for your information
and for your commitment to this
again i go back to the fact that
we've got plaques under every single
portrait
and and people don't really read those
plaques
except on a rare occasion for a rare
individual they might find
is there no way you could come up with a
reasonable compromise we have
a commitment
from the public to pay for this portrait
for a portrait of a likeness
something that people can really see
visually
something that people
just won't see words on the wall
and we all know that words are very
important and we all know that they're
very important uh
efforts and commitments that
weren't worth cheswell made in his life
that need to be memorialized but there
needs to be more than just a plaque
can you come up with a compromise of
some sort well i i would thank
representative but and i would say that
i've mentioned the signature
um
certainly uh if you want to commemorate
his
his ride you know with paul revere you
could have a figure on a horse
back um you could have a masonic
sign on this you could have
an image of the new market town record
book
you could have an image of his house i
mean there's no shortage of visual
attractions that can be put on a plaque
to get people to stop and take a look at
it and maybe even be more extensive
than that but there's no such thing as a
portrait of wentworth cheswell there is
no such thing
there is no such thing as a likeness of
wentworth cheswell
so that that's where we are and i i will
just say you know that we hope the house
will exceed to the senate
position because otherwise senator
carson says that we'll we're just going
yeah i think we will take a break
because i'm i'm
fairly certain that
the house doesn't see it that way but
we'll we'll have a conversation we can
senators uh
we've had our conversation we are
very much stuck on a visual um
it was interesting to us to hear you
mention
would the senate be amenable to
um
that type of a
of a an accompaniment to the plaque
of a rider on a horse
where that discussion of
of
the rider that rode north from boston uh
where paul revere rode west
um would that
be something that the senate would be
amenable to uh
changing their proposals
you know why not i mean i don't think
you need to change the language i mean
the plaque the process of deciding
what's on the plaque is something that
we would do
and um you could have right on a plaque
a nice image of the top of somebody
on a horse and you wouldn't get into the
business about his features necessarily
you know think of the tricorn hat and
you could have it right on a plaque and
i could the tour guide said did you know
that well chez will roll with paul
revere and he was from new market and
you know um
and i think his signature under it i
mean i think it's what we would do is
work with the
you know the with the deciding on this
and the wording is it's extremely
important as i know from the black
heritage trail putting up its uh trail
markers it's extremely important as
extensive committee work and historical
researchers who come up with a language
so that you have that right so i think
that it just that if you go to the black
and we we could just say we want
um
you know uh if you want to add something
with images commemorating his
accomplishments or his life you could
add that or just assume that in the
black the process is we're going to end
up with something like that so i don't
think we need to we should assume um
yeah so representative
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
but then we come up with the problem of
money because we don't pay for um i'm
sorry i can't hear you the problem is
the money then
because you say we can come up with the
money for the plaque well you know the
historic committee does the blacks
anyway we come up with the money for
that
but when it comes to someone on a horse
i i don't think the historic committee
is going to come up with something like
that we've already got a commitment from
the outside
from
what a portrait is so
i'm thinking we could still have a
painting
if the
if the masons in new hampshire are still
willing
for this kind of compromise to have
a painting of a colonial person
horseback riding from portsmouth i guess
it was to exeter to warn about the
british are coming
um make sure he's going in the right
direction
that would be rather significant to try
to put
all this on one plaque i think would be
expensive
i don't know who would pay for so what
what are you thinking of then
where we do have a financial commitment
from the outside there would be um
i think it would be
an opportune moment for fundraising to
cover the cost of this
uh
of this i think that that i do think
that would be accomplished
um
and uh
i think we are where we are
and if you'd like to put in some
language in this it says with
appropriate
images commemorating chess with cheswell
fine
um
then
i think we will need to draft
just for the assurances that it will not
simple
worded
plaque um i think we do need
either a relief we need something on
this plaque so that it
generally will show
um what we've talked about
um
that being the case we'll need to put
together something with ols and they'll
be signed off but i think we're in
agreement that um
that failing
to get
the portrait that we feel still that was
necessary
um
a necessary compromise might be the
the accomplishments mr chairman i hope
we could work out the language here
because if we come back and it's
language we're not going to agree to
this what what's the point and um
neither will we
let's uh what what do you we have the
senate version here what do you want to
um
it could say on line five well it says
this could say
accept the gift of commemorative
historical plaque for wentworth chiswell
including
appropriate
images
commemorate uh
go
oh i think an appropriate image that's
very vague
minus an actual portrait we have to have
a figure of since you mentioned it
figure of a man
on a horse this still doesn't
we have to have an image that's more
specific than what you've said senator
including appropriate images marking his
accomplishments
mr chairman thank you but he had many
other accomplishments besides riding
that horse
um
you know someone could very well take
that language and do almost anything
just have someone sitting why don't we
say appropriate images marking his
accomplish as
approved
by the joint legislative historical
committee
historical plaque for wentworth cheswell
including appropriate images
marking his accomplishments as approved
by the joint legislative historical
committee
and oversee the placement of the plaque
do we have we don't have actual wording
of what the plaque will say right i mean
i i i'm presuming the main point is that
it will talk about um his racial
qualities is that
or racial history
is that
going to be included well i i would i
imagine i'm sure you've looked at the uh
wording on historical marker that's
placed at his gravesite in new market
yes um that is an awfully good template
yeah and that went through the process
over there i mean again i was on the
i've been on the historical resources
committee
with the division of historical
resources and that vetting proc process
for language that goes on state
historical markers is very
very well done and so that could
certainly form a basis for it so but you
could add
appropriate images
marking his accomplishments
so including appropriate images and
descriptions marking his accomplishments
as approved by the joint legislative
historical committee
and oversee the placement of the plaque
i just want to make sure that we're
going to have
some
man on a horse in the plaque on the top
of the plaque and i think you may have
alluded to that in what you're saying
there as long as that's because a visual
is to me very important to the children
coming through the state house
um and and they may remember all these
you know other portraits but
riding on a horse and a plaque and and
and and i think that the racial
component of it is also very important
thank you yeah and i that's why i say
referencing the plaque and and the
historical marker newmarket because it
talks about his dissent
thank you and um
and and you know uh
i imagine representative wall you're
going to be on the joint legislative
historical committee since you've
probably been on there since there was a
history in new hampshire
thank you very much um senator um since
the first
physical thing that we know that
wentworth chaswell did
for our country was to
ride from portsmouth to exeter to warn
about the british coming after paul
revere arrived
in new hampshire
i do approve of him of an image of him
on a horse um
and i do but i think some of the
disappointment we've heard from
people today is that
and we feel
he was the first person of color
so that must have to be elected to
public office now i don't know
you know we're focusing on the image of
him on the horse for the revolutionary
war
um
is there any way we can besides writing
it in the plaque that we can acknowledge
that he was the first person of color to
be elected to office in the united
states
i mean i i don't know if we can put that
in the image somehow or not i don't know
well as i said
representative you're going to be on the
committee aren't you
[Laughter]
you're giving the committee a lot of
responsibility
and i'm i'll just say historically you
know don't get me started you know you
mean
but you know that he did things
significant to our nation's history
before he made that ride
because he was one of the early signers
of documents uh about you know
protesting british
authority and rule he was there from the
get-go uh on these things and that's
it's incredible you know he was willing
to fight fight for freedom in these ways
and uh
so i i just think and a plaque the thing
i like about a black too is that they
can be pretty good size and get a pretty
good number of words on them
and you know thank you very much for all
that and we do know that there's a lot
to say about him um do you happen to
know somebody who
is accomplished enough who can undertake
this kind of project
well i would uh recommend actually i i'm
sure you know the work of richard haynes
a very prominent african-american artist
and i think that tasked with the
creation of a
image of a rider or other things as well
and then there are others uh who do this
do design work
that the black heritage trail has has
used or the seacoast african-american
cultural center has used um
and
i would think that the you know possibly
the joint historical committee would set
up a little subcommittee that invited
some of these folks to participate in
creating the designs that that are there
so i think it'd be a good process and if
this passes we'd get right on it
you are you are submitting that in that
language we just discussed yes
mr mr chairman um
i you know i've been on other ones this
is a house bill so you'd have to submit
the language but if this is the language
we agree on
we can vote now and you can have it we
can sign off when we sign off we'll see
what os is drafted okay are we good
i think mr truman i just have one other
thing um in
the sense that we have disappointed a
lot of people with this decision
um we're satisfying some but we're
disappointing those who
wanted this image in the first place
can you come up with some way for us to
let the masons in new hampshire know
how and why we came up with this
decision because they were fully
prepared
i'm sorry is there a question in that
the masons of new hampshire
were going to pay for the portrait they
they
that's why paul smith was here he is
amazing
and um they had committed i don't know
if they you heard that testimony in the
senate or not
but they
when
we heard testimony in the house
the masons the order masons i'm not sure
how the term goes uh we're fully
prepared to pay for the portrait
so based on the fact that we have
changed our commitment to this
considerably
how can we
let the masons know that in good faith
you know they were enthused and more
than willing to come up with the
thousands of dollars that would come for
the portrait but clearly um i don't
think they're going to pay for anything
beyond that
how can we
justifiably give our apologies to them
please
well i appreciate that i appreciate the
masons as well um
again if you go to portsmouth um
the tavern building there which is
immensely significant for black history
that they
it is still it is still a masonic lodge
but it is also operated jointly with the
strawberry bank and they spent how many
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
restore that
um and to tell the stories of the
african-american inhabitants of that
that building so i truly appreciate what
the masons have done on this i would say
there's nothing to prevent the masons
from having a portrait made of wentworth
chisel which they could display
elsewhere
um i would hope that they would see and
we might include a masonic sign on on on
the plaque that you know and i hope they
would understand from this conversations
here which have been extensive what
the issues here are and i also would
hope that they would consult more
closely with the african-american
community in the future
um
when they have kind of concepts about
about this because uh i think that's
important
thank you very much
representative expedia thank you miss
sharon you know
i think you know i echo the the
sentiments but i do think that you know
if we do get more i know obviously
wouldn't have photos in the 1700s but in
the future if we do get any you know
anything with historical research i'm
hoping that we can
highlight him if we can get a portrait
if we ever got something like that it
would be great but um i'm hoping in the
future and you know i'm hoping like you
like you said senator that we could
diversify our walls
um because i think it is important for
our for our visitors who come through
that they see you see you know things
that may look like themselves
i appreciate but i appreciate your
work on this
thank you um i'd like to close it by
just saying i'm really disappointed um
i thought we would be able to do
something for the fourth graders
and and provide an image that they could
look at and
i am disappointed in the senate um
i will take a look at the language and
submit it and hopefully
we're not authorized to put it in the
state house they can do whatever they
want but we're not authorized to put it
you